some stories are so horrific they remain
Untold for years but Leona has decided
to wave her anonymity and tell how she
became a victim of a notorious child
grooming ring over a decade ago
she had a difficult upbringing yeah my
mum wasn't exactly well blessed her she
weren't
she had a few issues with her mental
health so she didn't and she didn't
really have the right role models to
teach her to be a parent
so she didn't know what to do with us
Leona was easy prey for a woman called
Amanda Spencer who befriended young
girls in Sheffield and then sold them to
child abusers
genuinely thought I loved her
so she was the person who confided in
she understood everything I said Earth
and she listened
and she said
she said that she was there and she said
she loved us and
she cared about she cared about me
I thought she cared about
like many of her victims Spencer took
Leona to parties at age 13 she was
drugged and sold by Spencer to a man for
sex
and then I was in a room
and then I woke up
through it
did you see her after that yeah she came
in with two of men and I was beaten
in front of her she beat me too
what must have been going through your
mind a bit why
what did I do wrong
I suppose that's how kids think though
didn't they like if they grow up always
being in the wrong
always being the bad child and if
something bad happens that's always
going to be your fault
you've obviously done something first to
start that from happening
thank you
I don't know can you describe the
journey home well there was no journey
home for a few weeks
okay
that wasn't a journey Hall
they needed to trust that I could go
home and be trusted
I said what happened after they beat you
up there
I spent weeks with them getting beaten
up raped and drugged
and then I was allowed to go home I was
allowed to go to school I was allowed to
see my friends
because they know that they could come
and get me whenever they wanted
after that Leona would regularly go
missing but says authorities lacked
curiosity did no one ask what have you
been doing I mean not just the police
but teachers or social workers what no
the thing was what do you think you're
doing
not what have you been doing what do you
think you're doing
my answer was always I don't know
I'm sorry
and was there any part of you that
thought here's a person I can actually
tell what's going on
no
no why not because nobody would have
believed me
they convinced me of that nobody's going
to believe me and if I do say something
what's gonna happen to my family
they know where I live my mum were a
disabled woman what's she gonna do she
can ring the police I can trust them
Connor I could trust them to keep my
family safe no
she alleges that one of the men she was
sold to was a police officer who she
later recognized when he picked her up
after she'd Gone Missing
did he say anything to you right in the
police car yeah he just spoke to me like
the police officers do
you know everybody's been worried about
you don't uh you can't keep putting your
family through this you've got a lot of
people out there looking for you and
you're wasting our Resources by doing
this
this allegation comes after The Police
Inspector it warned that poor vetting
was allowing sexual predators to join
police forces South Yorkshire police
chief Constable Lauren poltney who now
wants to meet Leona told Sky News what
happened to Leona at the hands of her
abusers is simply unforgivable and I'm
extremely concerned to hear today that
the trauma she faced may have involved
an officer who was serving with the
force there's no place in policing for
individuals who abuse their position for
criminal behavior and we proactively
root out those who do so
Leona didn't report the incident with
the police officer eventually she
escaped to Norfolk and one day the
police came knocking she'd been
identified by others as a child victim
I genuinely felt at the Earth every
because you didn't want to talk about it
you're trying to put it behind you tried
to pretend it weren't real if it's a bad
dream it doesn't hurt does it if it's a
bad dream it never happened
it's not real
it's been eight years since Spencer was
jailed along with one of the abusers but
the demons don't go away from the age of
13 to 14
how many men would you say rate you
I don't know
and in
as weird as it might sound I don't want
to know
I don't want to know because the amount
that I do know is
whether it was my fault or not well it
wasn't yourself I still feel dirty and
it's still it wasn't your fault
she has a life now and children of her
own but she can never escape the
memories
Jason Farrell Sky News